organizamos una manifestación aquí mismo
y un chico empezó a ser más y más
agresivo a decir cosas homofóbicas
cuando se sintió realmente frustrado
comenzó a maldecir nos y me escupió en
los pies smurfit
cada tres horas se denuncian en israel-
agresiones como la que sufrió nada un
caso de lg mítico fobia que en jerusalén
oeste se agudiza por el conservadurismo
y la multiplicidad de religiones
caminar de la mano no es tan fácil a
veces recibes gritos o te maldicen te
miran
tengo amigos a los que les han quitado o
quemado banderas de sus balcones a mí ya
otros nos han rechazado el alquiler de
casas porque nos presentamos como
homosexuales we came out es gay la
violencia no vence a nada siendo judío y
gay defiende férreamente jerusalén como
el mejor lugar en el que aunar su fe y
su identidad
hay gente que dice que está en contra
por motivos religiosos y no creo que sea
por eso creo que es por razones
históricas o de sociedad porque el
judaísmo en sí cree en la aceptación
exacta
pero cuál sea el pronombre o creencia la
mayor aceptación se da en la jerusalem
open house fundada en 1997 y ante el
desamparo del gobierno local a esta casa
abierta acuden cada año 30 mil personas
en busca de ayuda sanitaria educativa y
emocional
y
la violencia real aquí en jerusalén
específicamente contra la comunidad lgbt
más empieza con micro agresiones y va
hasta incidentes después está el hecho
de que la municipalidad de jerusalén no
apoya realmente a nuestra comunidad
si su marcha del orgullo existe desde
hace 20 años es mérito de la comunidad
en el desfile nada brinda información e
insignias y se moviliza con su grupo
religioso
todo ocurre bajo custodia policial y
militar luego de que en 2015 un judío
ultraortodoxo asesinar a la adolescente
syrah banking la violencia es un desafío
en esta ciudad muchas personas no nos
aceptan por motivos religiosos pero veo
que cada año va mejorando cada vez más
a jerusalén aún le queda un largo camino
para hacer de la igualdad diversidad el
fbi
también la palestina una norma en tierra
santa